This a whole experiment and self government is the best on the planet earth,
but without a doubt.
But this guy,
it's not his fault.
That is who he is.
But he exploited it.
He showed everybody,
he showed everybody the holes in this fucking goofy system.
I know,
but it's,
he's a reality star.
Man can be president one day and you could you and me,
if we could run,
that's the ticket.
If Rogan Rawlings ticket,
we,
we could win and I'm not bullshitting.
You know,
we can win.
I could do that too.
They did some fucking Vegas odds and they found out that I have better chances
of winning then a lot of people that would be freaking Rad.
Yeah.
There's like a whole like list of people who had better,
I like to see you just like throwing them out.
I got this,
but it's,
you know,
I mean no one's going to
work.
The most fun in that I'm having,
right this second is not even in this room.
So I manager my PR person,
her back there waiting on me to fuck up on talking about politics.
See I don't have one of those.
I don't have.
My manager is awesome and my PR person is nonexistent,
so let's get round three going,
let's go.
Here we go.
Seltzer Salute America,
America,
whoo.
I'm telling you,
it just keeps getting better.
Yeah,
it does keep getting better.
It's good whiskey or Tequila or whatever the fuck it is.
I forget now.
Yeah,
politics are the,
that is the one thing that,
that people say you shouldn't talk about.
But I like,
isn't that what helps us to talk about it?
It's just that people are so fragmented.
People fragment out everything you say and they're like,
well you know,
it's like,
it's like the,
you said something but then they turn it into this one little sentence going,
wait a second.
He said these two descripted averages and this fucking now and,
and this verb.
And look what he said.
He said cunt screening.
You heard him?
I told him if he would have,
I cut screening.com
I don't know what I'm going to do with it,
but where do you use it?
Well,
if we could just figure out a way to put micro chips in,
everybody will know everybody is and what everybody did and that way we'll know
if you're a cut.
He walked past this little thing and it goes,
beep,
beep.
You'll walk by.
He throws Burritos,
but he's a good guy.